[Applaudissements]
je viens c'est un mensonge qui durent
depuis des années sans doute le gag le
plus long de l'histoire de touche pas à
mon poste c'est parti
[Musique]
16 par 25 par 8 -
794 16 par 25 par mois
794 vous jure qu'il n'a pas d'oreillette
2406 ces jeux 1406 c'est la bonne
réponse boisjoli
mais non c impossible voilà ça la radio
cibl c'est depuis des années mais bon
connaissez mal dont la fin la radio si
j'ai pas de dons je suis noir mauvais en
calcul mental mais sinon c'est une
immonde arnaque non n'allez pas
d'oreillette j'ai regardé un canular que
j'ai fait à syrie depuis un peu plus de
deux ans alors ça a commencé à europe 1
c'est vrai et depuis ça continue et
touche pas à mon poste ne bat pas alors
de 1400 6 5406 c'est la bonne réponse
il compte d'un café de 1910
2005 4 06 29 10 et 20 05 ce qui
correspond à l'anniversaire de mon fils
de ma fille et de ma soeur dans le culte
tunisien